PROFESSOR: Convolution
is a tricky concept
and hard to understand.
But it gives so much
insight that it's worthwhile
coming to grips with it.
The Convolution:
Accumulation mathlet
provides one perspective on
the convolution integral.
I'll explain the
applet using a story.
There's a lake in Iowa with
a stream running into it
and a stream running out of it.
Farm runoff puts
phosphate into the lake.
The rate of deposition of the
phosphate varies over the year.
Most in the summer, none
in the dead of winter.
Suppose the farm is new
and that t equals 0,
there is no phosphate
in the lake.
This is called rest
initial conditions.
The question is, how
much phosphate is there
in the lake at some
later time, say t.
This will be an accumulation
of contributions from earlier
times, but the
earlier contributions
will have decayed
somewhat by time t.
We can visualize this process
using the Convolution:
Accumulation mathlet.
I'll set it up to model
what we're looking at.
The signal f of t is the
rate of input of phosphate
into the lake.
And I will model it by the menu
item f of t is 1 plus cosine
b*t.
You can see it drawn in the
lower graphing window here.
A certain proportion of
the phosphate in the lake
leaves it during
each unit of time.
This results in an exponential
decay of each contribution.
This decay profile is called the
weight function, denoted here
by g of t.
And I will select
the weight function,
giving exponential decay
e to the minus a*t.
Now let's see what
happens if I let
a small amount of time elapse.
How small?
Well I can select that
by picking the step size.
And I will select a
step size of one eighth.
So now let's let a little
bit of time elapse.
Say, amount of
time of one eighth.
If I click on the time slider at
one eighth, I get this picture.
t equals 0 happens to
occur at mid-summer,
so that the signal
has a value of 2
in kilograms per unit time.
This phosphate decays away
as water comes into the lake
and carries it off according
to the weight function.
And this is indicated by the
exponential decay function
here in the bottom window.
The weight function is a rate.
It needs to get multiplied
by the step size
before it gives an actual
amount of phosphate in the lake.
The step size is one
eighth, and the product
is the signal, the
value of the signal at t
equals 0, that's 2, times
the weight function, that's
the exponential decay, times the
step size, which is one eighth.
So that gives all
together one quarter
times that exponential decay.
And you see that drawn in
the top graphing window here,
the value near t
equals 0 is a quarter
and it decays away
exponentially.
Now let's move on to
the next time interval.
I'll click here, and
you see what happens.
The signal is now
a little bit less
and the time is a
little bit later.
So the weight function is
scaled and shifted a little bit
differently in this
bottom graphing window.
It gets multiplied by the
step size one eighth again,
and laid down on top of
the graph of the phosphate
arising from the
first time interval.
So the sum of those
two is a record
of the phosphate in the lake
arising from these first two
time intervals as it
decays away in later time.
This process continues.
You can see the next few
steps by clicking them up.
Here's the effect of
the third time interval
as it decays away, but laid
down on top of the preceding
contributions to
the lake, and so on.
Or I can animate
the entire process
and watch the thing
evolve as time increases.
So you can see, the
effect is a steady state
is reached after a while, you
get a sinusoidal total amount
of phosphate in the lake.
It's delayed a little
bit from the peak.
The maximum amount of
phosphate in the lake
occurs a little
after mid-summer.
Now imagine shrinking
the step size.
In the limit, as the
step size goes to 0,
this process is described
by the convolution integral.
At time t, all the contributions
from time 0 to time t
are present.
And so we're going to take an
integral from u equals 0 to u
equals t.
The contribution from time u
decays by the factor of g of t
minus u by time t.
So the contribution from between
time u and time u plus du
is given by the product f of u,
the signal of time u, times g
of t minus u, the weight
function evaluated
at t minus u, times du.
And the integral of
this differential,
from u equals 0
to u equals t, is
the amount of phosphate
in the lake at time t.
And it's given by the
convolution integral.
This system is modeled by
a differential equation,
namely dx/dt plus
a*x equals f of t.
The weight function of the
operator dx/dt plus a*x is e
to the minus a*t.
And the solution to the
differential equation
with rest initial
conditions is given
by the convolution integral
of the input signal
with the weight function.
This statement is a general
fact for LTI operators,
not just first-order operators.